Marissa Ray
tattoo meaning hang on I can blast
through this really quick
okay this was my first tattoo kind of a
burning man tattoo it means the line is
long but it is not infinite this is also
kind of a burning man tattoo this was
our camp art car called The sensatron
this is DND tattoo these are the death
saving throw dots meaningful and
practical uh this is because I love
Gmail
this is a Hollywood Boulevard star
because for three years I was a Street
character on Hollywood Boulevard to make
ends meet when I first moved to Los
Angeles and then this is my lemonade
stand that I had growing up and then my
most recent one I just got this is the
oh my sorry yeah the ashari symbol yeah
it was beautiful so thanks guys